siguen los duros combates en el este de
ucrania concretamente el foco está en la
ciudad de severodonezk e donde la
situación empieza a ser desesperada el
presidente ucraniano blogger michelle es
que ha dicho que el número de bajas es
aterrador lo que sugiere también que la
localidad podría caer en las próximas
horas son los próximos días en manos del
ejército de moscú recordemos que se
trata de una ciudad estratégica su caída
significaría darle una ventaja a las
tropas rusas de cara a tomar a otras
ciudades de la región como grama tos y
por otra parte en [__] las autoridades
ucranianas también han informado que
están investigando sobre la muerte de
12.000 ciudadanos ucranianos son muertes
ocurridas desde el comienzo de este
conflicto lo ha dicho el jefe de la
policía y ghor helmes y quien también ha
añadido que aún hay 1200 cuerpos sin
identificar se trata de verdaderos
desaparecidos de esta guerra en la que
como se ha insistido en las últimas
horas
también se están experimentando nuevas
armas